[Music]
i told you over and over again for god's
sake i felt glad glad i was out of that
ship
is that all yes yes
the smoke from your factory it's
destroying my home my my health my we
too are concerned about that pressing
problem
here let me show you some of our ads on
air pollution
it was louis pasteur who smashed the
belief
that microbes came into existence
by spontaneous generation
his opponents shouted and ranted against
him
but he performed his experiments
and silenced the unbelievers with
indisputable facts
[Music]
and i read this case history of this guy
who had had pneumonia and every symptom
that he had i had i went straight to my
doctor and he
diagnosed me as having pneumonia and
aids
virtually there in his office on the
spot
for we cannot be a strong nation unless
we are a healthy nation
and so we must recruit not only
men and materials
but also knowledge and science
[Music]
you